you think about like the dislocation
right now in the market where it seems
like stocks are you know relief rallying
if not really rallying but the economic
data we keep getting is going down right
26 million Americans unemployed 4.8%
contraction in q1 for the economy like
it just seems like the underlying data
and the actual reality on the ground is
way worse than the stock market which
seems to just be going in the opposite
direction yeah I think I think usually
we have scenarios like this where the
government comes in and intervenes it
drives the wealth gap right and so I
think they could current like rally
broadly speaking is asset inflation
right and so there is a massive effort
of to inflate the value of assets and
it's you can't you just can't fight that
right and so that's where you're gonna
see this stock is up we're doing X Y and
C or doing well or getting these funds
why this guy is unemployed etc right and
so those who own stock XYZ do well or
bought it let the dip this guy still
doesn't have a job right and so you see
that divergence in in unfortunately in
times like this with the government
action it usually drives the wealth gap
it doesn't know close yeah it feels
almost like it reiterates the point of
the stock market's not the economy it's
just the central bank actions represent
how do you think about the bailouts and
that government intervention kind of the
the next step of that I'm generally I
I'm not on the pamp that the government
should do nothing but what the
government is doing I am generally 100
percent of nest you know I am there's a
lot of companies that you know a lot of
people have the idea like if this
airline fails then we will have an
airline and and that's just not true
right when you're when somebody goes
boss with their house the house doesn't
disappear just a new owner shows up
right that guy disappears and so you
know with the airline's
these owners that created this highly
leveraged
dition right spend all their capital
buying back their stop didn't think
about like you know the robustness of
the stability which is okay I'm not even
gonna mop that it's okay if you want to
do that but you have to accept the risk
when something goes wrong in a leveraged
scenario you go bust you don't get your
executive bonus you get fired you
management comes in bondholders get
smashed they should have been paying
attention and the equity guys get wiped
out but the airlines are still there and
somebody will gladly come in put in some
capital and run it run it right and so
what we've done is we've removed that
right we remove that punishment and I'm
against it I would much rather have all
that money just be direct deposits into
the individuals pockets right which
actually helps close the wealth gap and
then let that money trickle into triple
up into whatever investments or whatever
is out there right but now we're flowing
money in to concentrate pockets of
businesses in industries right we're
picking winners and losers and letting
them distribute the money as they see
fit
yeah it feels like um what I know about
you I think they very much kind of the
United States is the best country in the
world and we have a significant
advantage around the American Dream and
kind of that belief that like we're all
entitled to move up in the world but it
feels like when you start to take away
the impact of risk-taking right the
actual negative side effects of when you
take risk and it doesn't work your way
you change the incentive structure right
and it almost feels like you start to
create this social safety net or
corporate safety net that they're really
almost incentivizes more bad behavior
moreover leveraging if you know
someone's gonna bail you out every time
yeah it also like it hurts other guys
and other competitors who don't get
picked maybe I have Joe upstart Airlines
and I like Haiti and leverage ratio it's
pretty crazy and their customer service
is [ __ ] you're building up your
customers right I don't know what
airline you are call it spirit clips not
not spirit because there's a lot of
people who experience but you know to me
but and you're like great this is my
shot to tape over like I'm going to get
those slots at Newark and I'm gonna get
those slot
aah and my airlines gonna grow but here
comes the government with seven point
eight billion dollars or seventy two
billion dollars you know it's a better
line that airline of that air line and
you get squashed while they get rewarded
right and so not only does the incentive
structure changed it just solidifies
incumbents right who probably shouldn't
be there right and just it just it
crushes the American dream for a lot of
people a lot of people don't realize
like there's people organizations
entrepreneurs upstarts right coming out
to compete who are not getting the
billions of dollars right and now it
makes their job even harder almost
impossible in certain cases right you're
almost in a situation where the
government's playing kingmaker to some
degree right they're correct you know
picking winners and the other data point
that I saw recently that just blew my
mind was there's a lot of workers that
are asking to be fired from various
companies because they can make more on
unemployment with the stimulus kind of
beefed up in the unemployment insurance
then they will at their normal job and
it feels like that's just one not
something that I ever would have thought
was possible but to it's kind of sad to
see right where people are literally
saying hey fire me from my job cuz I
literally can make more money on
unemployment than you're paying me to
actually show up here yeah that that's
that's interesting you know um I'm a fan
of like some sort of floor UVI right I'm
I'm at the point where I think that
survival just basic survival should not
be dependent on a job right all the land
is taken there's no living off the land
and farming and all that kind of stuff
so you're kind of forced into the
structure where if you're gonna survive
and eat you have to have a job right and
I think a lot of people will culturally
say yeah but of course but it wasn't
that way right that's not how America
started you do not have to go work for
somebody okay in order to survive most
people work for themselves right went
out went out in the West settled grew
their crops
whatever that that is gone
you can't do that and so there's this
force element to work like you must work
or else you cannot survive right and I
think that should be eliminated right
and I'm not saying teach me lavish I'm
saying like at the poverty level right
where you can survive I think that work
should be for thriving that being said
these levels of unemployment
you know we're I'm paying you you know I
don't know if that's an indictment on
unemployment or what they're paying
employees but I think that's a little
bit absurd
yeah to me I think that was the part
that I took away from it right was the
fact that the wages that a lot of folks
that are obviously asking to be fired it
has to be so low right it's not you know
$15 an hour type thing you got to be
talking about people who were probably
making you know 8 to 10 bucks an hour in
today's environment you know it's just
is sad frankly right but yeah and those
are people that like hey I would rather
work on my play or my theory of physics
or whatever it is they can work on if
they had some if their survival was
taken care of right if you knew you were
gonna survive you know I think that
would unleash a lot of creativity and
entrepreneurship out of the populace and
not force them to work in McDonald's
versus working on this brilliant cure
for X Y & Z that's gonna take five years
right and so um that that's the crushing
thing like people are missing about like
having a floor and take eliminating work
from survival is you actually unleash a
ton of risk-taking and entrepreneurship
and you unlock the creativity of many
people right there's so many people who
are in soul-sucking low paying jobs just
because they gotta buy ramen noodles and
beans and if they had their ramen
noodles and beans taken away they would
say f you to that job right and work on
whatever they were working on which I
think society would benefit